vous avez 44 ans quoi qu'il arrive vous
ne serez plus président de la République
à 50 ans qu'est-ce que vous ferez vous
serez à 15 ans de la retraite si
toutefois vous avez assez cotisé non
mais qu'est-ce que vous ferez la
politique c'est pour la vie non non non
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
si vous aviez 20 ans aujourd'hui vous
direz quoi sur les manuel Macron
d'aujourd'hui en exerçant votre esprit
critique
c'est dur
je sais pas
je dirais il peut quand même
il pourrait faire davantage ça pourrait
aller plus vite
[Musique]
faites pas attention c'est mon
photographe officiel dans des poses très
naturelles pendant que je bosse
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu me feras quand même valider les
photos Loïc à moins d'une semaine du
second tour de la présidentielle des
internautes discutent sérieusement du
torse d'Emmanuel Macron certains
s'interrogent sur sa pilosité zoom
persuadé d'un photomontage d'autres
préfèrent en rire invoquant Austin
Powers ou au ss17 beaucoup de références
musicales également avec Julio Iglesias
vous les femmes et ailleurs
je savais qu'elle approche du second
tour vous faisait du pied aux insoumis
au LR écolo meilleurs j'ai découvert que
vous faisiez aussi vous entier de
séduire les fans de BHL et de Demis
Roussos
pilosité généreuse du président alors
quelques petites réactions quand même
sur Twitter mondialement
il y a match réagi un autre qui dit pose
sur un sofa des pub pour un canapé là
c'est Macron et voilà
c'est drôle ce qui est aussi marqué
c'est son signe un peu séducteur en mode
Franck Michael regardez voilà
mais vous n'avez validé
j'ai validé sans doute la série celle là
est passé un peu
vite mais si des fans de Demis Roussos
nous écoute
et on peut peut-être avoir ce que les
sociologues appellent le marginal c'est
quand de Demis Roussos et de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui peut être un gros un gros
réservoir de voix si Marine Le Pen est
élu le 24 c'est une option à prendre en
compte ce sera la faute de qui
va défonceuse des Français vous me fait
rire c'est la démocratie c'est un chat
donc d'abord moi je suis jamais dans la
politique fiction je me bats pour y
arriver pour gagner un dernier bain de
full pour Marine Le Pen avant la
préparation du débat avec Emmanuel
Macron qui aura lieu mercredi moment
crucial de cette entre-deux-toux je suis
pas du tout dans un esprit de revanche
moi ce que je souhaite si vous voulez
surtout c'est que le débat se débrouille
se déroule sereinement
toutes les années de service
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu c'est
pour ça que je le dis pourquoi
la République
pour convaincre il y a un référendum
clair le 24 avril c'est que la candidate
d'extrême droite elle est contre
l'Europe et contre le climat serviteur
on continue à parler avec Emmanuel
Macron
[Applaudissements]